you ready
it's all you do say hello let's do it
hello everyone welcome to episode 25 of
coffee and commerce
with gary vaynerchuk myself
and today we're joined by warren
kornblum
the ceo of shadow randy group thanks for
joining us lauren hey it's a pleasure to
be here i don't know why it took you 25
episodes to get to me
warren why don't you create some context
for everybody who's tuning in give them
a little
two three minute one and a half minutes
of who you are
sure um started out as an advertising
guy originally uh from canada
um built my agency up um over a decade
or so
uh from toronto we expanded to toronto
and uh london
and um and then eventually to uh south
florida
and uh then sold to a company that was
then called bozell jacobs kenyon eckhart
which is now part of the inner public
group
uh worked there for a three year earn
out and and hated the job i had because
i went from being the guy who was in the
meetings to the guy who was doing
accounting and
all that kind of stuff and um trapped in
a corner office and um
uh then was recruited when i left after
my urno i was
recruited by um the then fortune uh 100
toys r us when it was a public company
and i was at toys r us
from for the last five years from when
it was um
publicly held until it went to private
equity uh
left when that transaction took place um
and then um through a whole other
securities route also wound up
at rooms to go as a strategist and chief
marketing officer
and then at certa simmons betting and
today what i'm doing is uh is board work
and advising uh companies both legacy
brands as well as startups so
legacy brands on how to defend and
startups on how to attack it's a it's
kind of a really cool perspective to
have
yeah i i actually live a little bit of
that life as well and i think it is
i think it is a fun uh way you get to
see kind of both sides of the equation
which gives you clarity
which allows you to kind of help sabine
take us away
one really appreciate the background um
so there's a lot uh
there's a lot for us to discuss we had
to wait 25 episodes to get you on so we
want to
cram everything as quickly as we can
let's talk about toys r us
talk about your time at toys r us um and
and
with the theme like we're talking about
um today and some of the
speaking work that you're doing your
overarching theme is you're
never too big to fail or too small to
disrupt
and and the um juxtaposition of those
things i think is brilliant i'd like
that to be kind of the theme behind most
of our discussion today is that i'm sure
it will be
but if you could just talk to us about
one side of that toys r us um
not necessarily where it went wrong but
what
you saw what you observed where the
it could have gone in a different
direction and what you feel about your
time
at toys r us and warren one thing that i
want you to touch on
because i know this is a short kind of
like blast of time with you
for the people there's a lot of
entrepreneurs i'm reading the comments
hello everybody on all the social
platforms that are watching
explain this notion of being you know
you having your own business and then
being part of something like toys r us
you know when i you know when i hear
your origin story you were playing the
long game
so you were making long decisions yeah
then you get into this environment where
you have to make short decisions
i'd love to tap into your brand on
something that you wanted to do in your
soul
right weren't that you knew because you
knew how to do things you did it before
but you couldn't do because of the
construct of the game you were playing
at toys r us and i think that will teach
people why big companies
do certain things that don't make sense
or may help somebody
make a decision today that may come out
to a different kind of uh
outcome sure and i think that's a really
great perspective the um
i guess that you know if i look at the
frustration you know i was actually the
um
the first time that they had brought in
a quote chief marketing officer and it
was also the first time i had ever been
a client in my life because i had always
been on the service side
um and i think you know i remember a
couple of really quick ones one is as i
remember the first day that i
i was i was on the executive committee
at toys r us and i remember walking into
the boardroom for the first time
and i you know i'm a marketing guy like
we all are and i said okay so it's not
rocket science my customer
my target is mom with kids i mean you
know and
and she was really a second generation
toys r us kid so the assumption was that
everything uh about toys r us forget
about reality perception was
what a cool store it's where i get toys
that's where i you know i grew up
um and i remember walking into that
boardroom and i said okay so my target's
mom with
mom with kids and the entire room was
filled with guys with ties
and i said to myself okay well this is a
bit of a problem
um and you know we all know as great
marketing people what you have to do is
you have to get out of your own skin and
get into the skin of the person you're
trying to talk to or the people you're
trying to talk to
i think that the biggest frustration i
had gary was
that toys r us became all about
logistics and uh and and cost re
reductions and
you know i mean when you talk about the
magic of being um
um a toy store and and taking advantage
of all the things
wonderful about childhood and parents
who want to get the perfect gift i mean
everybody at christmas time or a
birthday wants to be the one who gives
that kid the
coolest gift the one that they just put
out and you know i think that's that's
what toys r us would be the
the thing i really loved about my time
there was the opportunity to be a part
of the team that built the times square
store
because that was cool should have been
about not
not the fact that it was you know 100
000 square feet but that it was about
just in you could just see when kids
went in there they were captivated by it
experience
yeah yeah 100 percent so we lo i think
toys r us lost sight of its consumer
um and it became about running this big
12 it was a p l it was a
p l game i think that's right out
real quick big shout out to jennifer
burgess who worked at toys r us in 1989
danielle pollock not getting answers
she's bouncing out i'm sorry we're not
doing q a i apologize
but we're going to jam continue to jam
with warren zubin
warren you bring up uh the experience
and to shift gears for a moment
um i think everything we've been hearing
about retail anybody that talks about
retail at all talks about how retail
needs to shift into an experience and
not a transaction
because we get enough transaction online
that time square store and certain
stores around the world the m
m store and leicester square this that
the other right there experiences
you did it then um there are a lot of
uh to gary's point there are a lot of
folks that are following us that are
entrepreneurs or in d2c
and they want to aspire to do something
in retail
what are your thoughts around that
experience in retail and what does the
future experience of retail in your mind
look like
well i think the first thing is and it's
been mentioned i think gary said it a
couple times it's not about the
transaction
um the transaction is something that
happens if you do it right at the end of
the gate at the day
but i think that really to me a
successful entrepreneur out there or be
a d2c
or be it in physical space or be it what
i think is going to be the evolutionist
in both um is going to be able to really
create the environment
that their consumer that they've
targeted their entire business for is
going to say wow i really
you know the the biggest gift any of us
can give as consumers is time
time is precious something that we you
know we value and
from the time i walk into that store my
time has to be honored
um i'm a big believer in something i
call share of heart
you know we all talk about um it's
important for people to think of us to
think of us first to give us money and
all that but you know what when you get
them to actually
like you then you win
do you think that um during your
era there do you think that
you and the rest of leadership
underestimated the internet
from uh getting them to care and doing
brand building down there
and thought of it more in a
transactional manner if at
all and i think it's important i you
know i think i like talking about what i
passed on uber twice or many other
things
i think you build so much on kind of
like
i think you could teach a lot of people
and they're loving you in the comments
so i like the way you're communicating
you know i think about those years toys
r us is one of my favorite brands of all
time
me too oh so i'm a jersey kid
you know like even when lionel kitty
city was coming up in the 80s i was like
mad at the kangaroo i'm like no no
jeffrey's my guy
you know like you know that was when my
family made it
like being able to buy something at toys
r us was like a seven year journey for
me
until like we could afford it instead of
like you know and so
i'm just very curious like i feel like a
lot of people
i'd love to actually leave it at that
question going back
your organization's relationship with
the internet underestimated it
misunderstood it
mistreated it after thought help me
miss the boat entirely would be the
answer i would give you one of the
reasons that i
actually was recruited to go to toys r
us was and you'll probably remember
a lot of the younger audience won't but
you know there was this first wave of of
e-commerce that took place around 2000.
i remember
russ doing the deal with amazon well
yeah and then
and also there was a brand called etoys
that had you know
was uh a year old had a i think 50
million dollars in in total revenues
toys r us
50 years old so a year 50 12 billion
versus 50 million
and uh etoys had a market cap greater
than toys r us i think there was a lot
of
bad math in those days but our
e-commerce was awful and i'll tell you
um gary i was asked to to consider
coming back into toys r us in the next
generation of it
and to me i said that the biggest thing
is is you almost have to
you know physical stores have to almost
be second to
getting a really magical disney-ish
website going um and i just think
i think it was absolutely aside from
carrying too much debt load it was the
absolute death knell of
of toys r us was never ever ever
figuring out
um e-commerce and not even so much
e-commerce is a bad way to put it it was
bringing the brand to life online and
really creating a
an amazing place i think the thing that
you said and i want to get this in
because so many
entrepreneurs listen to this show zubin
that are early
and i'm always trying to make that
connective tissue to them because they
can't necessarily relate
to the level that warren played at where
it's a different place
what warren's saying to a lot of you and
i could tell by the way he's saying it
him and i are brothers and i'm excited
to build our relationship offline
is at some point toys r us
became how much money will we make this
year obsessed
not what the heck is going on with the
customer what do they want
and the second transformation happened
it was game [ __ ] over
a lot of you right now are in year two
of making eight hundred thousand dollars
from making thirty thousand in year one
and you're thinking about the house and
the boat and the rolex that you're gonna
buy
instead of feeding your business the
small company version of what warner
and zubin are talking about right now is
taking too much money off the table to
buy a bmw
instead of pouring it back into your
business i built my dad's business
very aggressively because i didn't take
any money off the table i was pouring it
back
into the machine which allowed for
bigger economics later for my dad
you see that connection warren you agree
you've got a club yeah
no 100 i also think that you know in
those days
as even as a public company and i think
it can translate down to
early stage entrepreneurs too in the
public world if you found out
and companies still do it today that
they manage their business for two
months the way they think they should
manage their business and
the third month of the quarter is
getting ready for the analyst call
and you do stuff that just makes no
sense whatsoever
you're appeasing you're appeasing wall
street right make it look like you're
doing something they want that you think
they want
exactly meanwhile that's completely
against what the consumer wants
exactly and they were basically voting
with their dollars and you know and i
think to your point gary even on
um you know the the the young
entrepreneur in their first or second
year
um and you're right about not it's not
about so much buying things but
even as you're looking to what do i do
with this business
you're absolutely right it's invest in
the business and most importantly invest
in the businesses ability to relate to
their customers
i want to um touch on something you
mentioned there a bit of a tangent but i
think it's really important for the
audience especially those
it's basically everybody here that
follows gary
often times people are wondering like
what is gary like in a boardroom what is
gary like in these meetings
um and you hit on a really important
point because
this is a constant conversation that we
have which is okay we've got this target
to hit that target hit etc this quarter
i think the critical thing here and this
is an aspirational thing for everyone
that's listening
is we'll go in somebody will say
something
most people 99.9 of people
will within that paradigm go okay this
is the problem
that i have to now solve how do i solve
this problem the difference between that
and gary is gary will be like okay
how do i flip this on its head how do i
figure out how to change that problem
completely
so that we can get the result we want so
that influence
i think is really important and to
understand that you can look at problems
now
again most of us don't have that
leverage don't have that ability
but to be able to think that way and
understand that ultimately
there are reasons and they could be
illogical reasons why a lot of these
decisions are made
but to have the ability to push back and
get to that point where you're able to
course correct without having to stay
within the confines of the problem
it's really interesting well in today's
i think in today's world safe sucks
it just does i mean you know it's
dangerous
if you play it down the middle you're
going to get hit with the ball it's safe
is no longer safe
it's not because the reality is is that
the consumer's
options and the speed of innovation make
it a vulnerability
absolutely 100 i mean look you know
again because i think we're doing a lot
of
relating to a lot of the audience that's
watching
when influencers didn't under like
what's going on on instagram right now
is organic reach is really getting
affected
yeah and so two years ago when i'm like
go on tick-tock they're like i'm
crushing over here
my ego doesn't allow me to start at zero
again they thought they were playing it
safe
now they're in trouble you just see it
everywhere yeah and i i think sometimes
you also
you overdo it right you play the hand
too much um
and at some point when you do that you
start you know with
those examples at some point you start
to almost become redundant
um and then people and when you get into
that trend thing on information and
influencers
it it all if there's not the credibility
then people stop listening
right and you know so um
the other the other thing that happens
and i see this in the music industry and
hollywood
and in advertising one of the things
this
i would argue the single biggest reason
that i am gary vee
is because i still want my ear to the
ground of my craft
warren i compete against executives and
adler as you know
that are the most that aren't actual
content producers
aren't actually running ads aren't
actually looking for business results
i am meta to what i do i'm a
practitioner
of my craft more than the people that
even work for me the most progressive
company yeah
i think that people lose their ear to
the ground
you know what got them there is i always
say i say this to a lot of people
and it's been really hitting for some of
my friends i'm like gary i'm
in i'm like my friend what got you here
is the thing that will get you to the
next place and you were convinced by
somebody not yourself
that it was something else i'm tripling
down
on what got me here i'm getting more
dirty more in the trenches
more engaging more content this kind of
content that kind of cut like
i'm i'm tripling down on the dirt and
people are so
quick to enjoy the fruits of the
penthouse
they lose their sensibilities flavor
taste strategy
context and ability in the [ __ ] game
warren
yeah no i i agree with you you know it
it's sort of gary only i 100 agree with
you and
it's almost like going back to your
original question about what frustrated
me to most of toys about toys r us
because toys r us lost its way
forgot who it was forgot why it was
there you know
um it wasn't about cubic feet of
warehouse and all that [ __ ] it was about
getting you know being the biggest
selection of and making kids happy and
making parents and uncles and aunts and
friends
be feel really cool for having been able
to do it so it was about satisfying
customer need and understanding it
and it was not about what it became
you're absolutely right i completely
lost sight of the magic of being toys r
us
what you and i remember as kids 100
you know don't count me out even though
i was in the clearance aisle the whole
time
i was there as well i love this dollar
buddy
i have like yeah i mean the the brand
association the
feeling the emotion behind that i think
all of us can
certainly relate to let's talk about
customers for a moment and lean in there
um you mentioned
you're never too big to fail or too
small to disrupt right
but if you're not too small to disrupt
what is at the core
of failure or disruption and how do
those folks listening in and frankly any
company because again you're probably
not too big to disrupt either
but what is it how do you disrupt i
think what you do is it
first of all it 100 starts with the
consumer in the middle of it and
understanding it's not
all consumers aren't created equal for
sure so based on what it is that you do
and who it is that's going to buy what
you do or be loyal to you
in what you do having a really acute
understanding of them and getting as i
said earlier getting out of your own
skin and getting into their skin
um the assumption is that you know it's
funny as you
know um later in my career i spent time
a lot of time in the mattress business
and
you know the the never too big to fail
is also a great example there i mean
here you got all these legacy brands
some of which i was helping and
serta and simmons and you know you got a
lot of other ones
um and eight years this should go
um you know there's there's a there's a
bunch of people who take credit for
being first
casper obviously was the raised the most
money for sure and spent the most money
on advertising but
you know casper purple tuft the needle
lisa they all came out around the same
time
what what was their key to disrupting
their key to disrupting was one
they realized that people just didn't
like
shopping for mattresses um they didn't
like shopping literally i would
literally
rather zoom punch me in the neck with a
hot iron
than go buy a mattress it wasn't enough
to just bunch you had to be a hot iron
as well
you know what didn't you like you didn't
like the fact that you felt like you
were going into almost like
they used to use the used card like i
like my i like my time warren
right right what the [ __ ] am i doing
like jump on this thing and feel they
all feel [ __ ] fine
yeah well but you know then there's the
other side of it which is that you know
the brilliance of these guys was they
realized the shopping experience sucked
so let's eliminate the shopping
experience
they realize time is of value so let's
try and make it as simple as we can
they realized that people had no idea
about what the value
prop in in mattresses was um
and there i think that the industry the
legacy people in the industry
including me did an awful job of
communicating what's the difference
between a three thousand dollar
tempur-pedic and a
casper there is a difference i promise
you there's a difference
but it it got obfuscated it just got
thrown out because the marketing was so
spot on by the disruptors
so is it being to answer your question i
think it's it's a real keen focus on the
people you're trying to do and give them
a solution
that's respectful of them not that
you're trying to shove at them
but that they sit there and go you know
what great i can get it tomorrow if i
don't like it i can send it back and i
don't have to spend a lot of money on it
and i'm not going to have some
sales person tackling me in the store
not letting me out the door until i buy
something
two thousand one
um absolutely as it relates to the
consumer
um and it might just be one thought by
the way as i'm thinking through it
one thought that's so good that it means
the whole time
at me i'm fine yeah there's one there's
two thoughts that's one that's so good
it won't even come out
here's the question going all the way
back to we mentioned about toys r us i
think that's critical you've got a bunch
of men in a room
making decisions for their customer that
are moms
buying for their kids right then on the
other hand
you have garyvee who is
chairman ceo of vaynerx and you go to
any other ad agency look at their
chairman and ceo
they're not involved a and b they're not
setting trends they're just trying to
follow and be an influencer right he's
setting culture so the question really
is both for you warren and for you gary
in your case warren when you look at
that boardroom how do you create more
diversity in the boardroom to better
reflect the customers
and then gary how do you how are you
not only looking at like being able to
comment on the direction the world is
going in
but actually deliberately setting
culture you're creating culture
you know zubin i'll jump in first i
apologize warren uh i really don't think
i set culture i swear to god i was
listening i couldn't wait
i don't think so i if you really like
here's a good one
whatever i'm gonna ask you right now so
i'll give you a second to give a good
answer
what i set and then i'll give you the
answer of why
that's not true so go ahead what culture
have i set
you've set the culture that's making uh
entrepreneurship exciting something to
aspire to
something that is as aspirational
let's talk about it okay well they're
you know kevin rose you know
uh the myspace guys tom you know sarah
blakely there was
people doing entrepreneurship on top of
web 2.0
and and so what what i was seeing was
oh the internet's about to mature
so i can put out content around my
entrepreneurship
but the bubble was already happening
right entrepreneurship was booming
you know in in that early you know from
95 to 2005
the internet created a macro structure
where entrepreneurship became
practical in a way that it wasn't for
warren and i
prior to that i might have
been funny in that i had a personality
that was so
comfortable in one's skin that i was one
of the
people amongst others that you know
captured people's attention
in the communication of it but but to me
i think it's because i rode
what was happening early and had i not
existed because this is how i think
about setting culture
if i didn't exist would it exist and i
don't think i've ever done anything
that wouldn't exist if i hadn't been
there i think i
i incorporate into culture
and consumer behavior at a speed and an
observation that is stronger than most
on earth
but i don't think i said it because i
don't think i do anything
that creates something that wouldn't
have been there without me
i think the 70 year old man in the
comments
the 12 year old girl the 18 year old
college student
the 34 year old single mom the 45 year
old
pastor would beg to disagree with you
well i'm going to read comments while
warren jumps in i i think
you know the first thing is is i think
culture is such a
such a tough concept not because it's
not something i don't believe in but you
know
when you ask people what culture means
even just listening to the conversation
it means a lot of different things to a
lot of different people
um and i think from my perspective when
you ask about that boardroom and what
could have been done differently first
of all you mentioned the word diversity
1 000 um but i think
it's it's also you know i've always said
to myself
when i had my own agencies it was it was
like i want to fill the room with really
smart people and i kind of hope i'm not
the smartest one in the room
um hopefully i'm the one who get who can
when the right idea happens i can just
jump on it
but it doesn't have to come from me and
i think when you talk about
you know so so what what is that that's
a culture of creativity and
and empowerment and stuff like that
right um
i think there's there's cultures that
are you know we're going to be
passionate about
our customers that's a culture you know
so i think culture that's why culture is
a
i don't think it's a universal concept
that always means the same thing
i think in the in the right environment
but what leadership does which is
probably where you're talking
to being about karen is he sets the
vision
he's passionate about it takes no
hostages
and is prepared to do it himself and
fall on the sword for it but he you know
it's
it's it's concise and you know what it
is
absolutely and the point that i'm
perhaps trying to make here
as i'm trying to figure this out is it's
not just that he's prepared to
it's that he does he enjoys it he
loves it and he loves being part of that
process 100 percent
and then look at that point from the
poor investor you know what you know
what's crazy about that
and as you just said and i'm reading the
comments i appreciate the kind words and
the observations
it's crazy what you just said do you
know what i said in my head as you've
delivered that sentence
humility the amount of people that look
at me
and don't see humility is almost
everybody except i see henry
you know like i i think it's getting a
little more obvious i think my
wordsmithing has changed
but i've always known that humility was
my superpower i'm an aggressive
communicator i have conviction
convictions incredibly easy to balance
with humility
it's just unique it's just unique and
then you add a little jersey street
and a little immigrant underdog and you
get a you get a
you get a formula but it's i think
humility is incredibly underrated
when i i notice you reacted to that when
i dropped that
100 you're absolutely right i think that
you know what but also what humility
does is i think humility
um entices people to listen to you right
versus versus the other way when you're
you know
people just start to turn that off and i
think humility also allows you to listen
to other people it allows you to
to not think you have all the answers um
and i think that it's it's it's an
absolutely
vital piece of any successful you know
entrepreneurs to
is the you know you can be aggressive
and you can um you can be
fairly you know confident in your
opinions but if you don't have the
humility
to believe to realize that it's not only
about you
i i think at some point you hit the wall
100 you're dead
if you're a leader that doesn't
understand that you work for them not
the reverse i mean
zubin has been very kind on this episode
thank you zubin but in private
meetings with me it's been one of my
most it's been one of my most delicious
relationships in the last two years
based on something very interesting
which was he had his own company i
bought his company
and he had a lot of reservations and
concerns that
it would be good and for me to
exceed his greatest optimism
is why he communicates to me the way he
does behind closed doors and it means
the world to me
it's [ __ ] flattering 100
but that's because i think i work for
him warren i bought his company
i gave him money and i feel like i work
for him well
in some respects you do and if we don't
feel that way then you know
you lose sight of what you're doing you
know what you if you didn't feel that
way
you know people always say to me so
what's your biggest fear and i always
say my biggest fear is fear of failure
um and it's not because i'm i'm i'm
afraid of failing it's afraid of letting
people down it's afraid of not having my
game on it's afraid of you know when
someone calls me into a room to advise
be it a startup or a big company it's
it's not
it's not feeling like i accomplished
something on their behalf or gave them
you know it sounds trite but gave them
added value that when i leave the room
it was a better meeting than when i
walked in
you know that's um to me i put in this
fear of failure maybe it's not fear of
failure but it's it's it's
that's that's how you define failure and
i think that for again for those of you
that are listening like oh i'm in a job
or i'm doing this this is the right
place for me what not
i can tell you it's definitely not the
right place for you if you are not
rooting for your partner your co-worker
your boss to be successful
nothing like a great team nothing like a
group
passionately about their success even in
like pick up basketball
like warren you just said nothing like a
great team i literally thought about a
single pickup game in 1998 as you just
said that
like there's random peeps and you just
gel
and there's just nothing like i always
go to that place as always i
occasionally go to the place of this
single pickup game
where the five of us should have never
run that playground that day we
shouldn't have won a single game let
alone six
but that's why i've always believed in
team i'm like these are five i think
maybe two of my friends were there but
punchline
five players that had never played
together most connections didn't even
really know each other
and sometimes it just happens and it
makes me believe in team the most
100 and you know i bet your gary if you
ran into and you remembered any of you
know the other three the non-two friends
you'd probably have that a connection is
last with two decades
right oh yeah we were there we did that
that was cool yeah i right now
want to give a huge shout out to
keyshawn and kenny i don't recall their
last names but in third grade
we had a baseball team and we were kind
of the diamond the three
yeah and like i feel feelings towards
them right now warren
that you can't imagine yeah yeah or to
play baseball
share a heart i'm telling you they got a
piece of you 100
yeah share of heart love it
this is fun take us away zuma i gotta
run do some uh
some family stuff warren it's such a
pleasure let's get connected to me and
maybe connect us on email
i'd love to share a meal at some point
or a drink virtually or something or and
i really appreciate your time
me too thank you keep up the good work
you know i'm uh
i'm a fan too so it's great for me to be
here and get to meet you guys both of
you
thank you thank you
warren thank you so much for joining us
audience thank you for the comments
thank you for uh engaging with us today
i hope you got a lot out of today
there's a milestone episode for us
episode 25.
looking forward to seeing you all back
in a couple of weeks warren thanks again
uh thanks for making the time and we'll
definitely have you back on
all right be my pleasure thank you
thanks everybody